walker buehler is third in the league
with those 11 wins his 2-1-6 cra leads
all national league qualifiers and as we
touched on just a few minutes ago even
better lately with a 1-0-8 era over his
last five games
and he's gotten three victories in those
five games and he has earned
everything about that earned run average
the strikeouts are really good of course
but
one of the highest ground ball rates
he's had in his career at 43 percent
he's got an era near six against these
red jerseys
fields two up and two down in the first
that is a sweet play right there going
down the back of the hill and keeping
your balance
that shows you a little bit of
intimidation to the fastball breaks one
off to get him this one was in the
strike zone
same result and mueller puts up a zero
in the first
here is reed detmer start number two
dodgers looking for the series win on
this sunday afternoon with trey turner
to lead it off again
down the line with a chance for him to
go around first and into second
it scoots by into the corner he'll hang
on to the lead-off double
max has felt lately like he's been in a
bit of a funk just out of rhythm at the
plate
muncie pushes that one into left field
to give the dodgers the lead in the
blink of an eye
two battles in and it's one nothing and
a basic for
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the first inning double
single double second and third still
nobody out
[Applause]
sharply hit the short muncie breaks for
the played high throw allows them to get
under the tag
everything coming up dodgers through an
inning today
first and second here's seeger both
runners take off stacey's throw not in
time
what an exciting brand of baseball
they're playing so far
[Applause]
oh two got him well that's a start in
and out
and now a tough right-handed bat and
chris taylor that's a big time slider
for
reed dappers getting the first out of
the inning
well strikes out taylor he escapes this
with just the two runs he's got to take
something from this
inning up in and
strike three demers in big trouble
strikes out three and limits the damage
to two
this is the guy who's hot who shouldn't
beat you gets in on it bouncer to third
running throw justin turner makes the
play
with some help from his friend on the
back end
let's see with the i mean that's sweet
so
close joe at first amazing pick
look at that justin turner came in the
dugout
limping and now went down in the locker
room now comes back out
and it looks like dave is convincing him
to take the rest of the day off and
justin wants to stay in
muncie center field marsh
leaves and he got it throw to first
turner diving back in brandon marsh
full flight impressive that is why he is
going to be a star in this game
two out for aj pollock there goes turner
on a ground
[Music]
[Applause]
pujols in for justin turner 3-0 green
light and above
career 96-76
way up there off of the bat of alberts
nothing second inning albert pujols
to play or not play fastball buying here
second game in this last uh
draft in the first round that one is in
the left field
that's going to get to the wall fletcher
with two outs got a quick start
up with the ball is pollock round 30 is
coming
and he's going to score here's the start
goose
hitting very good slugging very good on
the road
bueller feasting on that right there
with these couple of wide breaking balls
and if it ain't broke flag fix it three
straight breaking balls to go to
glaciers
angels on the board middle three five
one
he doesn't hit it that hard but he's got
this line drive approach a lot of times
his miss hits turn into blue pits
he does get a chase here one of the
hardest pairs in baseball to strike out
bueller gets with a curve
and ends the top of the four little
things he wants to remember
always there for him to look back on his
motivation
he's down swinging here with a back foot
breaking ball from bueller
strikeout number six one gone in the
fifth
the seventh strikeout for mueller
back-to-back case to open the fifth
the one-two he lost one to the left foul
territory max munsey by the camera well
leans over makes the catch
nice play by muncie playing third base
for the first time
this year because of the injury to
justin turner mckinney's the runner in
second
1-0 the count on pollock
grounds one through the left side base
hit his third of the day
mckinney comes home adele is
you can always give me the oh i knew
what you were trying to do
totally did fly to left aj pollock
makes the catch a one two three seven
for
boxitani phil
two one from myers taylor cracks one to
center field that'll
dunk in for another base set he's got a
couple blue picks today
the creator of barrels are overrated
showed that sign twice this afternoon
one on one out for bellinger who's over
three
seventh of the year and it's eight one
that fastball is hammered into the
corner that's extra paces
gosling's coming home holding third
is iglesias and that's two doubles by
adele
that he's pulled into that left field
side
what a rise justin bruhl from undrafted
to the major leagues
making his big league debut here his o2
pitch
strikes him out good morning good
afternoon and good night
first batter that he sees in the majors
big league debut for justin brewer his
2-2 pitch
tap back to him thought about coming
home thought about going to first he'll
come home
and get out of the end welcome to the
major leagues
justin brewer justin brewer fulfilling
the dream
trying to finish this game off he dies
striking out stassi a nine pitch ninth
inning
his first big league appearance ends
with him in the mound